he's lil rel actor comedian writer
producer and the show rel premieres
immediately following the NFL on Fox
doubleheader on Sunday September 9th at
8 p.m. live in all time zones makes it's
a time period premiere on Sunday
September 30th at 9:30 Eastern on Fox
whoa no pressure on you well yeah it's
gonna be even crazy when it's all with
the cartel yeah so how did where'd this
come from it's based on my you know my
standard material of my life I just
wanted to do a sitcom for real and I and
I decided to do with Jerrod Carmichael I
didn't know Michael show it and yeah
it's really I guess I'm still kind of
the more I talk about I'm still pinching
myself I just been working yeah until I
started doing interviews I'm like oh
yeah I do have a ship well you stole two
movies here uncle drew yeah and also get
out yeah
I start start with get out because
you're a TSA agent and get out and
you're on the phone you're not even with
somebody to ask how tough is it to act
and you're on the phone it wasn't tough
but what was cool about it the Alison
and Daniel they will actually be like we
were really supportive with each other
so would will just be it they were still
being a room on Days and it had to come
in it was such a creepy place we were
shooting at in Alabama that I think we
all just decide to hang out
I like why we got to make it like the
movie it was it was really weird like we
all hung out all the time it was like it
was a weird town he was an did you know
it was gonna be this good I remember the
first cut off saw I saw of it and I
loved it and I was like you know do I
like it because I'm in it we did what
was gonna happen forever like it was it
was a cool surprise yeah what do people
say to you when they see you I remember
when when a movie first came out it was
a lot of people just thanking me for
helping him and being a good friend
laughs I
we'll get like a hugs like thank you
you're a good person now you know it was
a scrip but now it's just a lot of it's
you know people not gonna air before the
TSA age is always excited and I'm proud
of like you know cuz I was such another
actress I are you tired of people
talking to you about get out all the
time I'm like no like a lot of us don't
get a chance to do like a good classic
movie you could do a bunch of I know if
we're gonna do a bunch of movies that
you don't even really remember like that
but to do something that people still
remember and talk about I'm okay with
that I think you should do a Funny or
Die as a TSA agent so just do something
at the airport and be your character at
the TSA better be fun to do a wheel Faro
like if we both like through also
moustaches and just be a TSA agent for a
day how good would you be as a TSA agent
well you know what's funny
we we don't take their jobs today
the TSA is like that they're just I help
us yeah they're really like our saviors
to be quite honest with you when you
think about it these regular people did
I don't know the training that great but
like this they're supposed to stop
terrorists could you stop the terrorists
your character and get hot definitely
like a riot was committed you know I
mean like when he went to the police and
told him basically we do we we train
just like yeah you know you was a cocky
yet also uncle drew you were great and
as I told you and I meant this when the
movie was done we immediately reached
out to the PR people because they said
who do you want to have on the movie and
I said we want low rel and then I find
out that you're a fan of the show so
it's great to have you and this is fun
to actually be sitting I'm such first of
all I'm a sports fan and uncle Drew was
one of the movies I did because I am a
basketball fan like that's I don't even
know what the pitch was for me to do it
I just remember I'm about to say yes I
remember to produce a talk gonna be
about I don't know why we talking I'm
gonna do it who did you want to talk to
the most out of all those great
basketball players Chris Webber I was a
huge
five five fan and Chris Webber Chris
whoever's still one of my favorite
powerful so it was kind of weird
so I've been with the first day I think
our first table read and I was like
preparing myself because I'm a big fan
and before I was able to say anything he
was like yeah I'm a big fan of comedy me
and my wife watch it and he was like
serious I he knew jokes and stuff of my
oh you and I had to be like I and you
messed up my moment but I had so I mean
so hated Matt talking about the timeout
like it's very it's really I had a had a
great couple now did you ask questions
or did you just listen to answer it was
both
you know the Trey what's happening at
the same time too with Kyrie one to
leave Cleveland already told us that
Kyrie got traded during the shoot doing
that we were shooting the club scene and
Tyrese brother whispered and it was why
we shooting there's like it gotta be
footage of him just walking on set in
the middle of a city what happened and
Kyrie was Carey was really excited about
coming to Boston and I thought that was
really cool and it was weird too because
I was watching sports it like I watch
sports stuff so the I had like me and
Carey had like a read the next day and I
like to not bring it up like I'm
actually man you good just watch sports
city you just got traded like this and
this one he wanted to leave so that was
free I didn't know I imagine even know
that was gonna happen like oh wait kairi
wants to leave Cleveland and you watched
it the night before you got to sit down
with him and read a scene and I'm like
look at her like yeah everything okay
man you grew up in Chicago yeah so Bulls
fan all day
white socks huge Bulls fan Cubs Cubs fan
yes I'm from the West Side Chicago okay
we you know the West siders will go with
the north side oh yeah cuz like I wonder
Andre Dawson curl that jheri curl
I had to post it was him Michael and
Walter Payton in tuxedos yeah well how
old were you when Jordan was dominating
I was I watched every like it was a time
with like my
parents used to make us we had a you
know I had to go to bed at a certain
time we had this little black-and-white
TV we had under bed me and my brothers
and we're like they would think we would
sleep like it and they don't make us go
to bed doing a good playoff game you
know every like it's gonna be like what
and they'll be watching hear my mom
talking crazy to the TV but we had a
little black-and-white TV so we used to
act like we didn't know and then I
usually listed a bull's radio tooth like
their little let us listen to the radio
instead of watch it which I don't know
do you ever meet Jordan I met him once
oh and no it was dope it's like it was I
was at a sports bar and Charles Oakley
who you know this boy brought him I
think brought him with him and it was
but it was it was a bunch of fine women
in this place right well Mike walked in
every dude just start staring at Michael
Jordan for the rest it was a weirdest
thing does a bunch of grown man just
staring at him were you famous at the
time no I was popular cago for comedy
which is why I was able to say I took
met Charles Oakley before and so what do
you say to Mike I say I'll say hey Mike
oh you didn't do him a big he has to
know like you know I am a big fan like
if I'm not a fan either I mean yeah
whoever walked up Michael I don't know
who you know idle comedy-wise growing up
oh man let me Richard Pryor you know is
the Godfather but Eddie Murphy is the
Eddie Murphy Robert Townsend Kane Ivory
Wayans you met Eddie Murphy briefly but
I would love to have a conversation I
like I want to sit down with Eddie like
it's so weird like Eddie has talked
about me to other people and I still a
metaphor wait he was talking about you
you're like in a nice way but he you
know who I am so I would love to just
sit down and like talk to him how do we
come up with the name Lorrell it's a
basketball story X is like my Oracle
story
are you or chol well this thing about I
don't know I was a nerd until I went to
right because I would it was a school
Providence a male in Chicago is a
private school and I went there and
everybody it was cool being smart like
we used to pick on people who had bad
grades how you get a C's you don't get
too much trash talking from this from
that group though well when I went to
the public school to high school I
remember the first night orientation I
dress really nice and I look at that
nerd and I thought they was talking
about somebody else I got taps about ASA
nerd and so the first like semester
first a quarter or whatever I was like a
nerd to everybody
yeah but how can you be a nerd at a
school full of nerds no I without some
glad you say that so I was at that
school then my parents couldn't afford
to keep me there they like look it's
time for your brother like they like
look one of y'all you did your private
school thing you got to go to public
school put your brother in school we
only go for one tuition so I had to go
to public school so I went from net
school to a public school
so being picked on whatever basketball
tryouts happened and they didn't know I
was like working on my game to host
humble of my cousin Darrell who played
on the varsity
so when tryouts came man I took these
glasses off and was balling them dudes
and I sit straight up and it was like
that one of the scenes I was dead it's
all just a real cut-up a little real
nobody know I'm named Milton so it was a
see it gave me a little real and that's
been everybody like people don't even
know my real name of graduation they
said my name what kind of game do you
have by the way I used to be a beast man
no I was because it's all to the point
we use that ok I'm not growing if I'm
not athletic like Nate Robinson there's
no way I'm making it totally I'm gonna
do comedy could you hold your own though
on a set of uncle drew no first of all
it was crazy watching like a switch went
off what like these are retired dues to
know but then they get competitive yeah
yo dig you don't know Lisa Leslie - my
hope since I retired and get on it
because it was real game
play man she had like six three straight
in a crowd like it was like really being
at the Rucker at one point where they
was all in their own zone
I mean well Chris well Chris whoever did
one crazy dump and after that he just
left the set his knees if I said you
could have Michael Jordan's career nor
Eddie Murphy's career ooh Eddie Murphy
Eddie Murphy yeah I mean Mike was is
great but Eddie Eddie's like I look at
my kids right a little but like they
know him from Shrek like he's just been
great at so many different times he was
the first comedic rock star
yeah but they can look down and see
their shoes and see Michael Jordan hey
man look Eddie Murphy is like Eddie it
wasn't about height it was a talent Mike
is still six six is that a gross bro
like I wonder what Mike would be if he
was doing like 511 do you think he would
have played in the NBA I don't know
depend on high I don't think he would
have
I don't think Sony that that gross bird
I mean it's it's funny here no stories
about the Grossberg I like a Scottie
paper have one too yeah you just never
had it now look at me you got nothing
going on in your life by Air Jordans
this guy doesn't even play no more how
many pairs of Air Jordans do you I have
a lot of pair I have a lot do you have
every pair that came out I think I do
actually a long with the new colors and
you know what your wife say when you do
this well I'm divorced now so she can't
tell me
is that why you're divorced because you
it's over yeah did she get one of every
shoe no my kids like imma die so with
everything 5050 no no you're supposed to
say nice this is my addiction it is is
by the Jordans yeah the show is rel it
premieres immediately following the NFL
on Fox doubleheader on Sunday September
9th at 8 o'clock a little bit pressured
there got to build an audience coming
right towards you yeah is his but it's
gonna be fun it's such a fun show so I
can't wait for people to see I'm tired
of watching the cuts I want other people
to watch it the series centers on low
rel a prideful self-made success who
lives by the code always believe in
yourself and great things will come yeah
also a divorced man whose wife is having
an affair with his own barber wait did
this actually happen I am NOT is loosely
based on my life and that's all I'm
saying hey congrats for your success oh
thank you did a great job in those
movies and you know we'll hopefully see
you again good luck with uh little realm
have me back man doing doing a
basketball season I look alright alright
we'll have you break down oh yeah no the
NBA not break down for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]